going on there citizens of the reject Nation
Greg here I'm going to play For You The Last
of Us video in just one second but in case you
did not already catch our special announcement
if you live in the Los Angeles area or if
you're just visiting Sunday February 19th
at nine o'clock P.M John can't be a Christian
harloff and I are joining forces to do a Live
show tickets have been selling thank you to
everyone who's already bought a ticket it's
going to be a night of Comedy a bunch of laughs
a lot of quantumania and then who knows whatever
else but maybe I can set them up to say something
to get them canceled I hope you're there what is
happening there citizens of the reject Nation
we are here to watch the fourth episode of The
Last of Us today how are you Andrew I'm doing
great I'm excited to see the continued journey
of Bill and Frank ladies and gentlemen yes this
is and the real rejects to get the gamer reaction
non-game reaction with Tyra and John which people
are enjoying that'll go up on Tuesday but in the
meantime if you're here please go ahead leave
a like also leave down below what you thought
about this episode that we have not yet seen
also subscribe click the notification Bell get
notified when our reaction for the next episode
of The Last of Us is up here on this Channel
full length Reaction watch along as we sing with
your own copy of this series available for our
super sexy rejects over at our patreon page we
cover several things over there exclusively with
reaction highlights and watch alongs including
and disclaimer we will make sure not to talk about
anything that would happen in future episodes
we will only talk about what happens in this
episode and how it pertains to the game we will
not spoil anything possibly for the future we
do our best and I think I said everything that
needs to be said let's watch the dang show now
you talking to me
it really is like a taxi driver's team
gas station the one from Terminator 2 right
yes nice how does that work that's
when liquid travels Against Gravity
because pressure you don't know I know it works
this is your fault then it doesn't matter
how much you push the envelope it'll still
be stationary [Music] volume two but we'll live
next in volume two look you get it two like t-o
what did the mermaid where did her
math class and algae bra I stayed
up all night wondering where the
sun went and then it dawned on me
here let's make you all nostalgic Hank
Williams it's actually before my time
there we go see I was seen for
scene this is that's a grouse
right on the reading but it
has some interesting pictures
please get rid of it it's your
horses I want to see what all
the fuss is about why are all these
Pages stuck together [Laughter] yes
great Recreation loved it and
they made it land just like it
Oh Yeah from the last episode you mentioned Orbeez
wow these shots really capture the Grim Beauty
all right that's enough for today
I thought we were getting
into Logan territory here
Chef Boyardee slow down this is slow what
am I even eating that is 20 year old Chef
Boyardee ravioli this is too remote for
infected anyway people dangerous people
smells kind of good well
that would be Frank's then
the rifle
I feel like it'd still be freezing with no
fire yeah they're on the East Coast Joe what
can I ask you a serious question yeah
why did the Scarecrow get an award
because he was outstanding in his field
did you read this no that was such an
endearing moment go to sleep I love that
he was really quick on his feet on
that one there's no way anyone knows
we're here right No One's Gonna
find us No One's Gonna find us
tick tock tick tock tick tock
let's set us their ass music
I'd be cradling that gun [Music]
Terminator level of paranoia man [Music]
Cafe Joe loves it oh what the [__] is that you
don't like coffee seriously what those Starbucks
in the accusing used to tell it smells like
burnt [__] yes I was waiting for that one
what's his name Who's name your brother Tommy
younger older younger why isn't he with you
so we enlists in the Army ran out of
high school a few months later they
ship them off to Desert Storm 12 years
later outbreak happens he convinces me
to join a group making their way
up to Boston which I did foreign
meets Marlene she talks me to joining the
fireflies save the world of course last I
heard he quit the fireflies too so now he's
on his own out there and I gotta go get him
can't wait for you guys to reenact if he doesn't
There's Hope For The World why bother going
on we haven't seen the world so you don't know
keep going for family I'm not family [Music]
your cargo what if you don't find
them how do you know I'm persistent
got up pretty early if you want to
grab more sleep I'm not even tired
great transitions
[Music]
he called her cargo [Music]
oh you know come on man
it's tense we can jog right around this tunnel
take the next ramp and we're back
on the road minute tops oh boy
let's try to see if anyone's like watching
them is a highway I can't tell from this
I'm all turned around so don't look at
the state map look at the inside either
there's some car man I mean I think we're
heading north underworld 2003 Matchstick Men yes
[Music]
I'm gonna help him
oh
no
nicely done okay yeah you're not heard
nothing I don't think so get out [Music]
just like the game
hey over the off-screen shouting
yeah when I say go you crawl to
that wall and you squeeze through and you
don't come out until I say okay [Music]
look at me I'm not gonna hit you hey
John you stay low you stay quiet [Music]
okay yeah that connection
between them yeah this is intense
oh the crawl
nicely done Joe
[Music]
oh [Music]
I'm in the mood for Doritos now yeah
get in there Ellie [Music]
yes that's what I was thinking
oh okay oh you know what to do
nice
one more no no no no it's okay it's okay it's
over we're not fighting anymore oh interesting
uh my mom isn't far if you can get me to her
finish the job yeah yeah for sure we
could be friends I didn't know wow
so real
you can have it it's a good night he's gonna
take it anyway get back behind the wall no
no no I'm sorry I'm sorry please please
please stop please dude's begging [Music]
didn't waste the bullet yeah let's just think
of that yeah smart Ellie I gotta
get in there I can't fit through
there's some stuff against
the door can you move it yes
go fast right I really like the way they
changed that scene yeah different location
than in the game beyond that like just
the more Humanity to everybody yeah yeah
I'm okay I'm good I uh covers up [Music]
yep
[Music]
what else do you want me to say I
don't know the truth definitely ah
you know where Henry has
this is so where my brother was beaten to death
I got sick I delivered you think
I won't do it I'm your doctor
that's a lot more depth to the hunters
who did this we think it was Outsiders
we found a truck ah Jeffrey
Pierce that's cool [Music]
I was like Tommy could be mercs
will he live there's I'm sorry
that's crazy they're humanizing
the hunters yeah imagine everyone
sorry for my excitement guys about
Jeffrey Pierce but I love Miss Tommy
yep there it is find every
collaborator and Kill Them All
oh my God
[Music] this is tense I know it's
like full on Military rating yeah
a little bit maybe search for supplies they'll
be coming through these places soon enough
it was like hiding out during
World War II are you okay
I'm all right this guard down are you all right
oh he asked her he shouldn't have had to him
when you're just a kid I don't know what it's
like first time that you heard someone like that
if you uh
hmm
I'm not good at this yeah you really aren't
I shouldn't have had two and I'm sorry
they really do work well together man oh
that's perfect casting it wasn't my first time
mm-hmm [Music]
you should have mentioned
that finger off the trigger
know who taught you that Central School figures
there you go look at
ever thought someone teaching someone
how to hold a gun was so adorable
you put it in your pack shoot your damn ass off
that's how the season ends she shoots her [__]
we'll get through this
damn they're good I know amazing amazing you
I want to see a scene where he talks
to Gabriel Luna yeah it'd be awesome
[Music]
yes love finding stuff like that
he's [__] close I can feel it yeah what
like these additional layers of the hunt
for Henry and Sam yeah also feels a lot
more personal too there's a reason that they're
hunting for them rather than it's just random
[Music]
is that what we think it is
is it gonna happen right now I didn't
think it was gonna happen this early
[Music]
wouldn't we tell the others not yet she said
in episode two bomb let's just handle what
we have to handle we can deal with this after
Kathleen after oh she's blinded by vengeance
seal off the building for now okay
damn the consequences I'm gonna get Henry and
Sam it's part of The Last of Us world man yeah
the Joel Ellie boost is that her first one of
the show yeah yeah take a look around first
encourage you be without me huh am I now
Wyoming oh yeah walked into that one [Music]
45 . wow this is so scary oh my goodness
hey you know the guy who said he was
hurt how do you know it was an ambush
I've been on both sides it was a long time ago
we did what we needed to survive you and test
and the people we were with a horrible
thing did you kill innocent people
come on
you have to survive yep oh 33 floors that's
good who hasn't been to the gym in a while
give me a minute get up you lazy ass
oh I mean yes 56 years old
you little [__] [Music]
smart smart just don't step on that
in the morning you sure you're gonna
hear it of course I'll hear it that's the
damn point we were talking about hurting
people what did you mean it wasn't your
first time I don't want to talk about it
you don't have to sign okay he's
trying to grow an interest in her
and asking her questions so it
gets easier when you get older
no not really you're really you'd hear the
glass or not because I've noticed you don't
hear Too Well from your right side is it
because you were shot there probably more
from shooting so if you want to keep
your hair and you stick to that knife
hey I thought it keeps hurting back and
forth to each other push and pull hmm
did you know diarrhea is hereditary
it runs in your jeans
that's a good tension breaker [Music]
I made him oh I love that that's so
goddamn stupid [__] Jesus I'm
losing it you're losing a big time
laughs
oh this is so cute [Laughter] oh
I know seriously he's got the feels I
really nailed those two casting choices
oh [__] oh damn
foreign [Music]
that was I'm telling you the pacing of this
[__] through the first four episodes is
unbelievable I'm so bummed I know like no I want
more were yeah I thought that was uh I thought
that was great I'm really digging the show an
awful lot yes you know like um it's great tease
at the end I I would like to go into it a little
bit but um yeah I mean even in fact you haven't
played the game I think it's pretty obvious who
those two characters are right I should hope the
audience who hasn't played the game knows who
those two characters are they kind of mention
them throughout the episode yeah yeah so uh it's
it's it should be pretty apparent who they are
um but I like the the way they ended off for
an introduction with them here I think that's
really great especially for non-gamers uh for
people now I won't say non-gamers or for just
people who haven't played the game I think it's
really smart but I mean beyond that like the the
emotional focus and intensity of this episode
I think is so solid you know like the something
that we were talking about heavy spoilers video
is how a a common thing for a common friend for
actors is the this thing called um the the prior
moment basically like what is your prior moment
before doing a certain scene so that often affects
how your current scene is going down right so
sometimes in this show what they'll do is have
these these scenes that are like dialogue wise
word for word but though more than just change
location the prior moment leading into this scene
where there's ripping straight out the dialogue
from a scene it'll still feel completely different
because it's got a different prior moment leading
into it or a different placement of when they
decide to show this particular word for word
scene like the scene on the staircase for example
um you know talking about hurting innocent
people and stuff like that and other moments
throughout you know like the car placement scene
was almost like exactly from the game like at the
very beginning also too in the magazines with her
with him in the game he gets extremely upset at
her when she takes the gun and shoots the guy well
yeah I mean yeah because that the whole that whole
thing was very different in the game yeah now that
we've gone to that point like there's this whole
sequence that happened at uh was it a hotel or
this is a hotel yes a little bit after no it was
not a little bit after test time it was after Bill
yeah it was after the bill was it was around this
time it was just a little further along than that
specific location where they crashed the car but
I love the addition that they do here because
you know like in the game when she does shoot
that guy it's just some random guy who tried to
drown Bill like it's just ah not Bill Joel it's
some random guy I try to drown Joel and then here
this dude's like humanizing moment Becky my name's
Brian like please don't and it and it drives home
that point of harsher decisions and like harsher
choices you have to make for survival and it's
it makes it more heartbreaking because like I'm
not heartbroken for the guy of course but you
know it makes the choice a little bit harder to
adapt to when oh now this person has a name this
person has an identity this person's crying like
it's it's a whole new ball game when you're you're
dealing with that level of emotion yeah it adds a
more realistic touch and even cutting to Ellie you
know on her own private time uh you know shedding
a tear over what just happened was a little more
badass in the in the game and here you're seeing
and that that was and I like that they did that
because I remember in the game Thinking Ellie
might be a little bit more like what we actually
saw here in the show where she does get like very
like they do have that conversation that you see
but this is something that I like actually cutting
to the perspective of her immediate aftermath
and the struggle of what she just dealt with in
that moment you know yeah for sure I mean it's
interesting you say that about the you know
the moment before that happens because that was
literally what I was thinking you know in terms of
that specific uh moment where you know she shoots
the the guy in the game versus where she shoots
him here and then the discussion that they have
yeah a lot of the dialogue is very similar but
because of I mean similar situations but different
parts like that whole exchange happens in the game
like immediately after with you know him getting
very mad at her whereas in this it happens a short
time after because they've gotten to hide now
where you made a great comparison felt like World
War II where they're hiding from you know soldiers
so I thought that was a great comparison but um
yeah and also too I I think an interesting touch
that they did in this is in the game for those of
you who have not played we kind of mentioned it
during the reaction the hunters are not touched
upon other than they're just hunting for whoever
is out there and they just want to kill you
there's no specific reason other than they're just
hunting you so cold-blooded [__] exactly okay so
I actually like the touch of you know there's
no black and white there is some gray there of
you know these characters are more humanized now
they've got this leader Kathleen played by Melanie
do you remember the blocky Melanie Linsky from
the Two and a Half Men and uh uh Ever After with
Drew Miramar but I I actually light up right what
she's not at the cave right no no no I was like
watching it yeah Kathleen is not a character in
the game and again with the hunters we don't ever
see a leader in in the in the video game so again
I thought that was interesting to touch the whole
Revenge story about two certain specific or one
specific character that she kept on mentioning
and again it just adds a very humanizing touch
to the character it adds a lot more layer and
depth now when you play the games like okay no
even though in the it's different contexts of
course but you can play it around in your mind
now but I that's one of the things I really love
about this show is they're not slaves to the
game yes they want to get some you know visual
imagery that they want to pay respect to yes
there are lines of dialogue they do want to pay
respects to but they they take you know they they
expand upon things we've mentioned that plenty
of times and but they do it in a very smart and
provocative way and again I just I really wasn't
even thinking like oh yeah watching the first
three episodes they're definitely going to expand
upon the hunters and give a an in-depth leader
that where I'm gonna feel a little more like
kind of sympathizing for the leader and why
they're searching for these characters but at the
same time I don't want them to find the character
so it's like again there's no there's no black and
white there's a gray area in there so I thought
that was a very smart decision by Craig Mason and
uh Neil druckman and again just really interesting
expanding upon the hunters and I know I'm sorry I
shouted so loudly uh when we saw Jeffrey Pierce
I was just so excited I wasn't expecting to see
him right there uh but that was so cool that they
got him in there yeah I made the joke that'd be
awesome if we could get him with Gabriel Luna I
want to get Troy Baker do a scene with Joel want
to get Ashley Johnson do a scene with uh belly
so let's make it happen Neil druckman I know the
show's been shot but just re-edit go back it would
be neat I'm finding myself on a on the experience
of this is is interesting because I'm finding
myself like there there are so many times where
I'm like that is from the game but uh before
in like the first couple episodes I'd be like
this is true from the game like I'll be freaking
out but now I'm like I'm so immersed in the show
that I'm just like having a kind of a quiet
acknowledgment in my head I'm like that that
is in the game but I'm I've just adapted so much
to this new version that it's just kind of cool
to take it on it's I'm really finding myself
taking in more on its own now more than ever
versus just constantly thinking so much about the
game even when I'm reminded of scenes of like oh
yeah I remember this line of this is this exchange
and stuff like that because they the way the the
the Friendship is the kinship I would say more so
the kinship between Ellie and Joel is developing
while similar it feels different yeah there's
there's more of a off-beat pairing about the
two of them you know in this one yet the chemistry
and the Coalition of them still it still gels very
much it still gels very well yet though I think
like physically there's just something about the
way that they look that makes them a little bit
more of an oddball pairing but that makes it more
Charming to me versus the because like but what
I mean by that is if if you were to just show me
the cover of The Last of Us game and you showed me
Joel and Ellie and you said they were father and
daughter I'd be like okay like they would look
like they look like their father and daughter
right we're here you get you really get the sense
of strangers who are forming a kinship here and
I like that kind of odd pairing between them it
makes it it drives home that character development
even more and having these like things with the
riddles and the little jokes that they're making
and the puns yeah the puns and when to put when
to place them at riddles was the hottest hardcore
riddles but the placements of of of those scenes
and like having the camping moments and um watch
watching in the private time of his protection
for her growing and I I love the scene when he is
struggling to connect with her and open up they'd
be like hey are you all he needs to be like is are
you okay and it's cool watching Pedro Pascal do
it because we've seen him do so many performances
and to see him play a guy who has like an actor's
job is to connect and people in her bullets to see
a guy really like be such a believable version of
someone who can't do that is uh is really uh it's
intriguing to me on a lot of levels there was one
thing specifically I mentioned if all else fails
there's one thing they have this was during our
trailer reaction uh the final Trail reaction of
this show if all else fails there's one thing
they have to nail on the show and that's the
relationship and the chemistry between Joel
and Ellie and so far through four episodes
I mean Hook Line and Sinker it's been absolutely
beautiful it's endearing it's adorable yeah there
are some you made really good analysis on
some differences from the game to uh what
we've we're seeing on the show in spirit I feel
a lot of similarities but yes I agree with what
you're you're saying but I mean there's just so
many little character moments that I just deeply
appreciate and I'm just getting so emotional I
mean obviously I'm emotionally connected with
these characters in the game obviously but I'm
I'm talking just straight up from the show the
chemistry that these two actors have with each
other with belly and with Pedro Pascal is just
unbelievable they just the Rapport they have
you just instantly get at least for me you just
instantly get connected with these two characters
I just really love watching them I think my
favorite part too yes it's it's the softer more
vulnerable moments I that I deeply appreciate
those are probably some of my favorite moments
but I love when they bag on each other like
there's just something so in there's something
so cute and endearing about that and also too
as I pointed out when he was teaching showing her
how to use the gun like again I normally wouldn't
say that that's cute but that was really that was
really adorable I just again just everything they
do it just gets me more emotionally attached to
these two characters and they're both just doing
such a wonderful job I know everyone when belly
was originally cast like she doesn't look like
Ellie now granted I had never seen Game of Thrones
I heard she does a phenomenal job on that show but
I mean to me she's just doing such an amazing job
as as Ellie she's just like again she's got that
bad out that badass Persona in that smart mouth
but the chemistry that she invokes with Pedro
Pascal it's just it's really beautiful to watch
they're so electric together on screen and it's
just really it's really beautiful to watch it's so
endearing so I I really I really love what they're
doing with each other the Rapport that they have
with each other it's just it's it's it's really
sweet well yeah I'm really taking it I find myself
comparing way less and just taking the show on its
own merits as time goes on and I love I love that
experience and I think episode three really helps
set yeah yeah the play the playing field for that
good good point like because episode three is so
different that I'm it is easier to kind of just
take whatever I'm getting now on like just what is
the show doing and just leave it at that you know
and because like you know Pedro Pascal's version
of Joel feels very different to me than Troy
Baker's and it's cool to have Bella Ramsay here
whose version feels very akin to Ashley Johnson
to Ashley Johnson feels so akin to it yet doesn't
feel like she's playing Ellie it feels like she's
not so pretentious to say it sounds like it sounds
like she's being Ellie you know and and I I love
that you kind of you got one that feels very
in a lot of ways very accurate to the game
and then one that feels like they're they are
doing their own thing but both feel very natural
and nuanced and lived in and uh yeah I'm really
falling for the the the the the tone of it and
so much of the character development of these
two seems to be in a lot of just moments of quiet
like Quiet Moments yeah uh private moments moments
where you this exchange of looks and not like
big dialogue scene like the dialogue's important
but so much of the character development and
and the understanding of them seems to just
be in the body language and in the eyes oh for
sure and and again like the the private moments
I I think that's really neat like to have a
moment like where Ellie's Crying by herself
and then if you and then the next scene when she's
with Joel it's it's like she wasn't crying she
doesn't even play it like she's covering up you
know what I mean like you would if they deleted
the whole thing of her crying you would not
have thought for a second that she's covering
up tears and I think that makes it even more real
because it's a real version of covering up yeah no
and just adding on to what you say too like that
that one of the last scenes that we saw there were
Joel just thought that that pun joke was just so
stupid and you see him finally smiling letting
his guard down and you just kind of see that
Humanity starting to come back towards Joel and
that love that he felt the love he had for Sarah
and the Beloved protection and now it's you know
that he feels that way towards Ellie it's just
really blossoming really nicely so yes I love
it and granted We're not gonna talk about what we
think was underground that was starting to come up
um although Gamers you probably know it that's
exactly what the [__] you know what's coming
off yeah you know it's you know it's coming but
I think like one thing I did appreciate about
that moment with Kathleen is she's so blinded
by Revenge which again I can't go into spoiler
territory about future events not in the first
game um I just think it's an interesting theme
again being so blinded by Revenge to get
you know to get your target that you're
gonna sacrifice everything else and you know
lose your Humanity over it it's an interesting
you know theme to come by and just to see that
again I like when they play around with that I
think it's very interesting so I'm yeah I again
I just didn't expect to get so many different
layers there with the hunters I just that was
just I should have thought about that you know
with how what they did in episode three and what
how much they've expanded just in general with
the first two episodes but that's why this show
is so smart I'm like I don't give any damn cams
about the hunters in in the game like shoot and
kill them all but like here it's again while I of
course want them to defend themselves I don't want
you know Joel Ellie and the two characters we saw
at the end together of course I don't want any of
them to get hurt of course not but again just when
you humanize and give us an emotional connection
to these characters and a relatability it's like
damn Neil and Craig very nice touch because I
hated I hated these [__] in the game like I
wanted them to die so bad well that's the cool
part about it is this the while there's you
know like in that whole thing with uh when the
truck gets smashed and then they they fight the
hunters and stuff like while there's like some
good visual motifs that make you that hearken
back to the gameplay of that moment what I like
about what this show does so well is that it
doesn't feel like they're just trying to recapture
what the gameplay looks like they're they really
drive home the the humanity and the violence
like the violence hits and they they more go
so go for the emotion that the characters must
be experiencing in this moment more than let's
do a cool visual Recreation of the gameplay
of because there's there's a scenario where
you could do that that's what most video game
adaptations would attempt to do and really fail
at it and then here they they don't even seem
bothered by it while there's like little parts
for the most part I'm not like oh damn they're
doing that thing it looks like just a cool moment
from when you're playing in the game it's and I
I like that they lean more into they keep it all
thematically and emotionally based and even even
in these scenes where they could just easily go
let's recreate what the gameplay is like yeah
for sure and it's also interesting too in the
last two episodes we barely I mean obviously in
this episode we didn't really see any in fact I
don't think we saw any infected in the last
episode oh I mean it's a big part of Last of
Us is mammers man yeah no no of course but I I'm
my point is that that's why I try and tell people
who have never played the game like yes there are
zombies are infected whatever you want to say yes
they are in there but they're really a backdrop
part of the game they're not it's not a it's not
a zombie infected type of game where that's the
main focus like that's just it's a part of the
world but that's what Primal survival humanity is
what this show is about as the world is is uh is
about yeah yeah but I think they're doing a great
job of like you know taking a little break from
the infected on a couple episodes and then you
know getting into the humanity of this character
is fleshing out these characters you know showing
us the survival of the fittest moments and all
that stuff so I and again just the stuff they're
doing with Ellie and Joel is I really love these
two actors so much they're just so they're
great so great together so I'm I and also too
I mentioned this right right at the start of the
review this show I know we're only four episodes
in again this is through four episodes this is one
of the best paced shows I've ever seen it's really
well placed it's really low there's never moments
where I'm like even on the last episode what was
it like an hour and 15 but whatever it was I was
like I'm even when they go slow burn when they go
actually I'm never like this is really dragging
it's really off balance with with the the pa the
pacing is really not there they're always right
and again that's not it for someone who has like
watched other people and know people who work
in the film industry it's not an easy thing to
to bounce and get something well paced it's very
hard actually and through four episodes Absolutely
they've nailed in my opinion they're executing
the [__] out of this and I'm loving it yeah
all right guys what'd you think about this
episode leave your thoughts down below
um look out for John and Tara's reaction and you
can follow Andrew on Twitter thank you guys so
much for hanging out with us especially if you
made it this far in the video please subscribe
if you haven't done so and we will talk with
you all soon thank you for being here [Music]